google condamné à une amende de 102
millions d'euros en italie rome
sanctionne le géant du web
motif avoir refusé sur sa plate forme
google plaît l'application 12 passes
cette dernière permet de trouver des
bornes de recharge pour les voitures
électriques
le gendarme de la concurrence transalpin
évoque un abus de position dominante
le moteur de recherche américain a déjà
été condamné à plusieurs reprises sur le
continent européen pour les mêmes
raisons dernier à mende en date infligée
par bruxelles 4 milliards à 300 millions
d'euros
on en parle avec cyril dalle - chercheur
à l'institut thomas more spécialiste des
enjeux du numérique
bonsoir sert également merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation sur arte france
qu'est ce que cette condamnation traduit
exactement bonsoir merci pour votre
invitation
en fait cette condamnation comme vous
l'avez justement fait remarquer années
que la dernière en date d'une multitude
de condamnation ou qui est un qui
interviennent tout en fait sur la même
logique à savoir des abus alors qualifié
d' abus de position dominante dans le
cas italien mais qui sont en fait des
abus je dirais plutôt des fêtes taille
systémique par rapport à fait en fait à
des géants du numérique qui va
aujourd'hui non pas de concurrent en
europe et indirects du coup c'est
presque stratégique dans la démarche de
ces géants du numérique à savoir
utiliser leur taille et à et du coup tu
es la concurrence et empêcher le
développement de la concurrence en
favorisant leur propre les applications
google on l'a dit a donc été condamné à
de multiples reprises sain pour ce motif
d' abus de position dominante 4,3
milliards la dernière fois il ya eu 102
millions ici 150 millions d'euros en
france l'an passé
les amendes se suivent et se ressemblent
mais ne dissuade pas google pour autant
pourquoi
et qu'est ce qu'il faudrait faire en
fait le problème comme j'ai essayé de
l'expliquer et il est vraiment
systémique c'est à dire que
le droit européen de la concurrence gène
empêche même l'émergence de géants
numérique européen il faut bien
comprendre que historiquement le la
construction européenne s'est fait à une
époque où la la la la mondialisation
n'existait pas l'occident représenté
près de 50% de la population mondiale ce
qui aujourd'hui à elle ne représente
plus qu'un -2 9% en fait le petit nom
représente moins de 9% de la population
mondiale et surtout les règles de droit
de la concurrence ont été pensés pour un
marché intérieur
fermez donc ces règles s'appliquent
defacto aux états membres de l'union
européenne mais elle ne s'applique pas
ou alors de manière très légère et
tardives aux géants du numérique
étrangers du coup en fait comme vous
empêcher l'émergence de géants numérique
au cas où vous vous êtes toujours en
augmentation avec ces gens du numérique
étrangers qui eux peuvent bénéficier
d'un certain nombre de mesures fiscales
de londres et amant mais est ce que ça
veut dire que les géants du web les
légats femmes comme on les surnomme est
ce que ça veut dire qu'ils sont plus
puissants que les états alors ce ne sont
pas forcément le plus puissant que les
états mais là en fait c'est vraiment une
question de philosophie c'est à dire que
les états unis 1 passe commande à leurs
gars femmes
iliad a beaucoup de commandes publiques
on peut citer notamment la dernière
commande en bad de l'armée américaine
auprès de microsoft pour 22 milliards de
dollars
la commande précédente pour microsoft
était 11 milliards de dollars
les entreprises chinoises font
exactement la même chose
or les entreprises
entreprises européennes en fait sont
coincés par le carcan du droit européen
de la concurrence
du coup vous infliger la commission où
les autorités indépendantes de
concurrence des états membres vont
infliger des amendes aux géants du
numérique étrangers mais mais finalement
dans leur stratégie de développement en
fait
leur objectif est en soi de racheter
deux manières preda thouars des
entreprises européennes qui vont qui ont
un potentiel de développement soit de
les empêcher tout simplement de
d'acquérir une taille critique pour
devenir concurrentes
c'est une véritable stratégie qui mit en
place donc l'amande
ils vont la payer ils vont utiliser tous
les moyens possibles de lobbying et les
moyen procédural ce qui est normal
puisque comme toute entreprise disant
droit de bénéficier des mesures de
droits de la défense et que c'est un
mais ils vont faire traîner le plus
longtemps possible
en revanche les entreprises concurrentes
concernées elles n'existeront plus une
fine et quand ils auront payé l'amant
donc en fait c'est ces impies merci sur
les allemands d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
chercheur à l'institut thomas more
spécialiste des enjeux du numérique
c'est là